i am not an expert in the field you're
not but i want to be seen as an expert
the thing that you're asking for can
only be earned too many people think
fake it till you make it is real i think
everyone is so convinced that the money
is an expertise and i actually think
it's in the enthusiast you're not going
to trick them gary i don't give a [ __ ]
what you did with those seven videos
gary nice to meet you nice to meet you
gary
i'm a little bit nervous i've been
following you for quite many years now
and uh i was uh telling my mom yesterday
i was gonna meet you and uh
she's from spain and she doesn't speak
english so i can send her the gabriel
the
spanish page and she was like i love
vittar you have to meet him
i mean she's my biggest
source of positivity and i think you're
the second one so yeah i'm very humbled
for that anybody anybody look
thank god we now have more of a
generation of stay-at-home fathers
but obviously it's not confusing that
the majority of stay-at-home parents
or are our
mothers that have been historically
when you were lucky enough and actually
by the way i'm so happy that we are now
in a mature conversation where
one of the things that most bothers me
in the world
is that women
feel guilt
to
have a career and parent it's really too
bad it really is and something i think a
lot about and like
you know how you think about stigmas
that are not stigmas today but they were
50 years ago
one of the things i hope i get to see
before i die
is that that stigma goes away because
it's really unfortunate on the flip side
and i'm seeing this more from men now
because they have an easier task at this
if you are passionate at staying at home
and raising your child
if if that child has a parent
that
is positive
for real
and especially if they're practical and
positive
the odds of success are high as [ __ ]
that's really cool like i'm just so
i know the biggest thing that happened
in my life and it's not even close is
that my mom
was
my parent
and and i think my dad for that a lot as
well because we were really poor
and luckily his old school
point of view on the world
enabled her to stay home with me because
it completely formed who i am
having a positive
parent but a positive stay-at-home
parent
or even not a stay at home having
positive parents is a big deal
it's awesome
it really helps um help really helps to
have something positive
during your education and as you're a
kid it really then helps you
to see the difference between positive
people and a bit more negative
and having people like you that's
constantly replete you that you you need
to
be positive all the time and
i mean really help so thanks a lot for
that
um my question is real quick if you
don't mind gary yes so i can i'm just
really excited about this
because it's just hitting me i want to
say it
i've still not heard a good answer for
why to choose negativity
i love this conversation i have so many
friends i love when people try to
disguise it on being real
gary i'm not negative i'm keeping it
real i'm like real negative
like it's i really believe that life is
how you see it every day there's good
and bad and
i i'm glad we're talking about it go
ahead gary
so uh
i'm uh i'm about to to start building a
brand a personal brand something i've
been willing to do for quite a long time
and now i've recorded seven uh videos
tick tocks that i'm planning to to post
uh starting august first so i want to
have a few ones uh just in case one a
day that's my goal and i'm scared
of what uh judgment of uh not being sure
i'm gonna be
i'm doing the right thing
and actually my question uh
to give you a bit of context so
basically the last two years i've been
uh traveling and working remotely
and i i really enjoy that lifestyle and
i want to build content around that it's
my
i agree
it's it's incredibly
clear to me that that's what everybody
under 18 wants
i love the youngsters one that for sure
a lot of the 50 year olds want it they
just can't see how to get there because
they have so many things that ground
them but go ahead
and you know two years i still feel that
i am not an expert in the field you're
not
but i want to be seen as an expert
that's why you're scared
exactly
so my question is how do you find a
balance between i mean i know i need to
document
how do you find a balance between
documenting
but still
creating content
and you look like that people look at
you like you're the expert or you're the
man to follow you know in the end the
thing you're asking for is earned
what do you mean
the thing that you're asking for can
only be earned
you haven't earned [ __ ]
this is why everyone struggles
the thing that everybody wants can only
be achieved
when it's earned
you haven't done anything
too many people think fake it till you
make it is real
even if they don't think of it that way
they think of it the nice way the way
you're doing this is very important i'm
really happy right now this is something
i haven't been able to dig into as much
as i want which is why i was so ready
with
it's earned i've been thinking a lot
about it
but you're not an expert
but who is an expert and why should you
even try to be an expert
i don't necessarily i never thought for
one day that i was a marketing expert or
guru or genius
i just was executing every day
and then talking about what i was
executing and then
they decided more than me
you're trying to get them to believe
that in you for your own self-interest
but you haven't done anything for them
yet more importantly why can't you just
be an enthusiast
i think everyone is so convinced that
the money
is an expertise
and i actually think it's in the
enthusiast
and i think just by changing that word
everything changes
you're not going to trick them gary
i don't give a [ __ ] what you did with
those seven videos
not going to trick them
but you don't have to
i don't want to that's the theme well
you do want to you don't want to trick
them
but you want them to think you're an
expert
i mean i want to build a you know
a business owner i believe
i i understand
that's why you're vulnerable and i think
i have the patience i don't well you
definitely don't
it's okay it's okay you definitely don't
because even the way you're thinking
about it your core question is how
quickly can i make them think i'm an
expert so i can make money
that's your actual question
i knew i was going to come with a
question there was a
a little bit of a [ __ ] question
there's a reason patient panda and
patient pagan
exist there's a lot of work to do and i
need two teammates
that's i mean it's i don't think it
should do anything to anything but it's
alpha i mean like that's the point of
the thoughtfulness of the project
there's a reason they both exist it's
that big of a task
it's the one
it's the one
you you lack the patience to earn the
thing you want
but i think you have it in you and so
i'm telling you
go with enthusiasts instead of expert i
believe most people 18 to 22 if they
just say i'm gonna be a blank enthusiast
instead of expert
takes the pressure off of them tricking
their audience for their self-interest
will maybe give them time in fact i
would argue that words matter
i would argue the word enthusiast
actually might even make some of those
kids
enjoy the process more because i'm an
enthusiast not i'm an expert which gives
them imposter syndrome which creates
anxiety and creates a non-formal
structure
if you're an enthusiast now you're in
documenting right and
creating i think that i think i'm gonna
build on this over the next couple of
years i think switching
expert to enthusiasts puts people in a
framework that gives them a better
chance of succeeding
and stick with darwin thanks gary
enthusiasts i'll go with that one and
and then
and then
thank you and then
i think the thing to think about is
this this is back to the 50 do you know
why the 50 year olds can't do what
you're doing is they've created
financial friction for themselves to do
it and they're factoring in nor almost
predominantly their children's
well-being and and most parents parents
unfortunately not these two awesome
parents think think that moving around
is like bad or something or like people
like overvalue stability
and undervalue curiosity and learning
the real world it's too bad it's gonna
take a couple generations though yours
might be it probably the one after if
they themselves aren't in university
structure if they themselves are
spending 20 to 30 living in 19 places
they become the 45 year old parents that
actually do see
this the narratives are so wild we're
gonna uproot our children from their
world and take them to a different place
or you're gonna create new contexts of
learning and and empathy and curiosity
like it's fascinating anyway nonetheless
you
genuinely genuinely
genuinely
are in such a beautiful place you knew
you're gonna ask a [ __ ] question and
you didn't know why
because you thought you're okay with
patience but you're not
because the way people define patience
is different
you're talking to somebody
and you know my story who at your age
was going to work the next 14 years in a
liquor store
and people want to be tick-tock famous
in 14 hours
let alone days let alone weeks let alone
months let alone years
right
and so if you're an enthusiast
if you're not if you don't have the
expectations of extracting money out of
people to pay you to be like you and you
just document being like you
and have better intent for your audience
you're more likely to extract money if
you choose to
and i know you always say
that we should not care about people's
opinion but how do you practically do it
well let's play
who do you think will most carry weight
for you
whose opinion you're most worried about
like
cool people on tick tock
which you could be i understand that
like i'm not saying like it doesn't
sound like it's gonna be your mother
she loves you and has the framework in a
good way too much
so who
i think would be like friends like
even old friends even people i don't
even talk to anymore
what's he doing who does he think he is
exactly it makes sense i i just i
don't know how to say this in any other
way
it'd be a really bad idea to not follow
your dreams
because of
tyrone from fourth grade
the big thing is
even more interestingly
i want you to go through that
adversity is the foundation of success
if you feel like you're not ready for
that
that's the thing you should most be
doing anybody who's listening if you
feel like you're not ready for friends
to judge you you should be putting
yourself in a position to have friends
judge you more
not less
[Music]
you